democrats seriously freaked out after
learning voters are apparently fed up
with their woke policies the blowout in
the san francisco school board recall
election it's not the only warning sign
internal polling shows the democratic
party is losing on key issues from covid
protocols to defunding the police to
immigration so the big fear is that the
gop the republicans are winning the
culture war there's dread real dread
spreading among many democrats that
their urban-based party could go extinct
in rural parts of the country some
candidates are afraid to even tell
voters in those those parts which party
they represent even the liberal media is
telling democrats to get it together
democrats are afraid the party's going
too far too many democrats just don't
speak in terms of the average american
comprehending what they're saying the
democrats have got to step away from the
super wokeness i mean san francisco
really tells what's going on if you give
the republicans the ability to point the
democrats as this super woke culture
focused on the wrong things that don't
matter to voters you're going to lose
and it's that simple well danny does
she's right about that dana but what
about that that notion that the
democrats could go extinct in areas like
where you grew up well it's starting to
happen i mean and it's not republicans
that are saying that it's people like
claire mc i'm not claire um heidi
heitkamp who used to be the senator from
north dakota
she's looking at this across the board
john tester said something similar last
week he's from montana and if you look
at some of these states you are seeing
the possibility that the democrats are
going to be completely boxed out they do
really well in the cities they have
focused heavily on the cities but if you
start to see some of the working class
pull away from democrats and that
includes non-white working class which
has started under president trump and it
could accelerate if republicans are
smart about things and also because
we're in the middle of this political
realignment and a geographical
realignment with people moving and jobs
moving right leaving the upper midwest
and going to the south with right to
work states i i don't think that the
democratic party is going to go extinct
but they are at a point right now where
you've seen at this flip that greg's
been talking about for a long time that
all of a sudden the republicans are for
the working class and the democrats are
not and the democrats are for the elites
and it is a little bit mind-blowing but
you're seeing it every day and i point
out that you know if you just look at
the school board members that got
recalled that was 80
margin in san francisco in san francisco
so imagine in a swing county or a swing
state there's not that many left but
that margin is going to be just
incredible for republicans this year do
you
is it incredible judge i mean you're a
politician you were uh do you sense that
these midterms will be the route that
these the intelligentsia are saying
i'll tell you why geraldo because
they're talking about these culture wars
and americans are talking about the
issues that matter to them financially
gas food prices and safety wines
and so everything that the the left is
doing from defunding the police to
immigration and by the way
january apparently was almost 200 000
people came through in january i mean
immigration southern border yeah the
southern border so which is like double
what it was the month before so
americans are saying to themselves we're
feeding and housing and educating all
these people we can't afford to put food
on the table we can't afford the gas
prices and these people are talking
about wokeness let me tell you virginia
was a bellwether this is a bellwether in
san francisco
and they want to say this is all because
of donald trump and it's all because of
racism
closet republicans there isn't a closet
republican in san francisco or anywhere
in new york
closet and yeah it's got to be some
closet but i'm a closet republican i
mean nobody knows i'm a republican until
they read wikipedia uh you know preachy
judgmental greg uh yeah i mean that's
people people get annoyed with that yeah
well locism is not the opposite of any
political party it's the opposite of
forgiveness that's why everybody is so
disgusted by it we predicted this it's a
one it's a 100
kind of political entity like marxism or
maoism it's not a human behavior it's a
construct that this human has to be
forced into right that's why nobody
likes it it's but except for academics
who live in some kind of abstract
universe and somehow it this infection
intimidated itself into the democratic
party but now it's eating the party from
inside
the solution i see is that that you need
democrats need to have democrat leaders
find former workstars to de-program the
current workstars this is what you did
with cults in the 1970s
i did the story yeah they did bring
former members of a colton but right now
what you're seeing from the morning joe
the alar strategy which is to act like a
republican so suddenly you know you're
tough on crime you want to cut taxes you
restore the order of priorities that's
because you want to win and so that
raises the question if it takes being a
republican to win
why don't you just be a republican why
do you if the
if the population wants this stuff and
you agree that it's important why do you
pretend to be a democrat when guys are
when times are good and then become a
republican when times are bad well it'll
be interesting to see how many stick
with it uh remember when uh
barack obama said uh bin laden is dead
and general motors is alive well there's
a new one uh buildback better is dead
kobet is alive inflation is rising can
he shake
can the president who came up with that
one uh not me but uh closeted republican
geraldo
so
the fact though the question is can
the democrats shake off this burden
no they can't shake inflation that's for
sure and they can't shake off and they
can't get billboard prices or crime or
the open board that's too much to shake
off they got cocky because they won a
few culture wars remember they won gay
marriage they won marijuana legalization
but they lost the war on christmas
geraldo and then they lost the vax man
o'reilly waged that that's right i'm
claiming victory for myself and purple
heart they and the reason why they're
losing many reasons why they're losing
this particular woe culture war is they
went in with a divided army
most of the democrats don't even want
this crazy stuff you think charles
barkley chris rock dave chappelle
uh the guy on hbo bill maher these guys
snicker behind the scenes at 37 genders
they're always taking pictures with
police officers they don't buy that
garbage white working class democrats
black working class democrats they don't
get into all this stuff they just want
safety and good schools and a regular
life the problem is you have this sliver
of insanity and that's mostly in college
campuses pundits on television in
congress that push this wicked stuff and
they're so loud and obnoxious the rest
of the party is like okay okay just
relax over here and they don't want to
say anything because they don't want to
get canceled themselves and now it's out
of control i think the real reason
besides twitter made people so crazy on
the left is kovit they stopped going
outside and talking to regular people
they used to have little clambakes
remember politicians used to go to
barbecues they used to shake hands in
the district they used to meet people
and they used to get a vibe for the
country about what the country was
feeling they don't have that anymore so
the quicker the cove is over the quicker
democrats could get back to normal what
happened with the democratic party is
that the most active
members like aoc in the squad they they
stole the march on the the old school
democrats
they were trying to figure out what was
going on and aoc was so far ahead of
them grabbing all the headlines all the
issues and you know what they should
nancy pelosi should have squashed all of
that the day that alexandria costa
cortez boycotted her office about
climate change on the very first day
they didn't do that they accommodated
her and now they have to sit in this
now they have to sit in it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else